non-fiction books all weekend every
weekend on book tv
now we travel to the santa fe festival
of the book for a writing workshop with
hampton sides author of ghost soldiers
during this hour event he talks about
the process he went through in writing
about the rescue of american pows in the
philippines during world war ii
it's a real pleasure to be here uh here
in santa fe where this book uh ghost
soldiers all began
and to be home once again after being on
the book on the book tour for
the last four months
i want to thank susan cantor and the
friends of the of the santa fe public
library for inviting me here as part of
the santa fe festival of the book
i'm thrilled that ghost soldiers has
received the sort of attention it has
it's all been a tremendous
and welcome surprise and extremely
gratifying to me because from the very
beginning i undertook this book
primarily to popularize
a chapter of our past that i thought
should be better known and because i'd
felt all along that the worst kind of
history is history that doesn't get read
not a day goes by that i don't hear from
veterans and their families in phone
calls emails
and moving and often beautifully written
letters from loved ones
who never knew the real story of what
had happened in the philippines who
could never seem to get their husbands
and fathers to open up the book seems to
have struck a nerve across the country
we we now have more than a half million
copies in print
universal pictures is now at work on
film uh film adaptation
the british german
dutch australian korean
and italian version of the book are all
in the offing
i have to confess that i prefer the uh
italian title of the book much much more
than the the english one i just got it
in the mail today and i'm just thrilled
i gotta show it to you so
fantasma
i think i think that's really nice much
better than the english
but as i say you know it's it's
tremendously exciting but fundamentally
ghost soldiers is not my story it's
rather the story of the courageous men
and women who populate its pages
and whose long ordeal has somehow fallen
through the cracks of our history
without their forbearance and
cooperation this book wouldn't have been
possible they gave freely of their time
even though talking to me often
necessitated opening old wounds
i relied on their correspondence
their war diaries and personal
scrapbooks
their published memoirs or non-published
manuscripts
throughout the process i was continually
amazed at their honesty and poise under
the merciless burden of memory spending
time with them was for me a tremendous
honor
on april 9th
1942
78 000 american and filipino soldiers
laid down their arms to the japanese
imperial army for nearly four months
they had fought a relentless siege in
the malarial jungles of the bataan
peninsula on the philippine island of
luzon
it was our first great land battle of
world war ii
starving in their foxholes feeling
abandoned by their country
left to fight with insufficient food
medicines and ammunition
they took to singing a chant that has
become their company slogan
where the battling bastards of baton
no mama no papa no uncle sam
and nobody gives a damn
finally they were ordered to capitulate
it was the largest surrender in american
history outside of the civil war and the
beginning of one of the darkest chapters
of modern warfare the prisoners were
force marched some 75 miles north in a
plotting atrocity that came to be known
as the bataan death march
as many of you know this was an event
with much local significance because
more prisoners from new mexico than from
any other state were caught in the death
march
this is why we have buildings and
libraries and avenues named bataan all
over the state
and this is why every april 9th
we fly a white flag over the state
capitol here in santa fe
the death march proved to be only the
beginning of the prisoners ordeal
however they languished for three years
in squalid concentration camps spread
across asia
the main camp the largest camp was
cabana tawan it was the largest american
pow camp ever established on foreign
soil
the great trial that these men suffered
in that camp was truly one of our
national nightmares
one that was inflicted upon thousands of
americans men who are now gradually
coming to the end of their lives
ghost soldiers is the story of a handful
of these men it's a story of how they
endured their ordeal of the sacrifices
that they made and finally of how in the
11th hour
the u.s army returned for them and one
of the greatest rescue attempts in our
annals the ranger raid on cabana tawan
this is a story that i think all
americans should be aware of these
prisoners suffered enough for a hundred
lifetimes and no one in this country
should be allowed to forget it
they endured three years of gratuitous
and often surreal mistreatment which
they still can't fully understand
they're old men now but sometimes they
still wake up in the night sweaty and
scared tormented by visions
their rescue at the hands of the rangers
ranks as one of the more one of the most
poignant triumphs in our history i hope
that their story will begin to take its
rightful place in american popular
consciousness and that the ghosts of
baton will in some small way be redeemed
i'm going to talk today a little bit
about how i wrote ghost soldiers what
some of the particular problems were
that i encountered while writing it why
i wrote it the way i did in the end and
i'm going to read a couple of passages
from it that sort of illustrates some of
these problems uh that i was kind of
grappling with
the the first problem and really
the major problem with this book for me
was that i didn't want to write it as
history with a capital h you know i
didn't want to write it as a a macro
look at what was happening to the us
armed forces in asia i didn't want to
look at particularly what was going on
in washington or in tokyo or with
macarthur i really wanted to get it down
at the ground level and follow the the
fates of a handful of men who were who
were there and experience it from their
point of view
um i felt like it would be a lot more
visceral it would be a lot it would be a
lot more vivid
in the end
if i could create characters that were
memorable and who you cared about so
that when you
experience the atrocities that they
experience you you care about what
they're seeing and what they're feeling
and hopefully come to care about what
happens to them in the end
when i was reading about the baton death
march there are plenty of books out
there about it and it's it's a grisly uh
kind of reading to do
but one of the problems is so often
these books are
um
a name comes but comes up and then
another name and then another name and
then another name and it's very um
numbing after a while you read these
horrible things that are happening to
these people that you don't know you
don't know where they're from you don't
know
what they did before the war and i think
it's just human nature that you you just
try to care but after a while it's very
difficult to keep track of all these
names and all these people so i think
the task for my book was instead of to
um and i think this applies to all
nonfiction writing i think
instead of um
following the fates of hundreds of
people thousands of people interviewing
hundreds of of different
sources uh i decided to go in deep uh
and get to know a handful of guys really
well really closely and try to see this
whole experience and feel this whole
experience from their point of view
the passage i want to read
right now has to do with the baton death
march
you know i felt like i had to work a lot
of history you know embed a lot of
history into the into these stories
nonetheless i mean i i had to explain
why we were in at baton in the first
place and
why the surrender happened why the
supplies did not get to them um there
were a lot of points of history that i
had to work in but i wanted to kind of
tease it in or feather it in in a way
that was uh so that you weren't actually
conscious of the fact that you were
reading uh reading this this sort of
straight history and to do it in in the
midst of scene painting um where you're
where you're really on the ground on a
specific day
the weather is a specific way uh and uh
you know do it in the form of scene so
what this passage i'm going to read is
uh it's uh april 10th and there's a
character named amy abraham who is
somebody that i got to know quite well
while doing the research for the book
he's uh from he's a syrian american from
pennsylvania he's still alive he's quite
a character um among his many exploits
he uh still holds the the national uh
tree sitting record from the 1920s uh
he's a tough guy and uh he uh is not i
don't think he's built like
you and i um and he got through this
whole experience and and we sat in his
living room and and we we talked about
it for hours and hours and he had
written his own book which i used as a
jumping off point and i was able to kind
of i hope and
at least what i was trying to do is get
this
experience in writing in a vivid way so
that you care about what happens to them
the water was pure and cool and raced
from the hillside as though from a
natural spicket
a.b abraham stared at it lustfully as
did the dozen or so other americans in
his group who all stood at attention
the japanese guard had halted the column
along the east road at a spot only a few
yards from the spring
but he would not permit them to take a
drink
sergeant abraham couldn't tell at first
whether the guard's decision to rest at
such a tantalizing place
was deliberate or
absent-minded torture but it was torture
nonetheless clean artesian water
filtered by stone splashing in brisk
freshets from a hole in the jungle the
sight of it was unbearable the thought
of it
the thought of not having it
abraham tried to avert his gaze but he
couldn't his mouth was cottony his lips
were cracked his tongue fell thickly
over his teeth for five cruel minutes on
the afternoon of april 10th 1942
abraham and his comrades
stared
a b abraham was a staff sergeant in the
first battalion of the 31st infantry
a syrian american abraham had grown up
in the wrinkled steel country of western
pennsylvania and had done a tour in
panama before shipping out to the
philippines in 1939
a gregarious pug-nosed man with tattoos
coursing down his arms abraham had been
a champion boxer before the war
he was a fast-talking plug of fellow
scrappy stubborn and hard and yet now
even he was beginning to flag
abraham had a small piece of shrapnel
lodged in his back and a slow healing
bullet wound in his thigh
but his immediate problem was thirst
he hadn't had any water since morning
when his group first stumbled out of the
jungle and assembled on the main road
the guard abraham felt was intoxicated
by his new power
he could not conceive of any other
explanation for how a person could be so
cruel
the men were dying of thirst
and water was right there it was
plentiful and free and it would not take
much time for the men to get a drink yet
the guard made the prisoners stand there
and listen to the soft babble
finally one of the men in abraham's
group could take it no longer he bolted
from the ranks and threw himself upon
the spring with relish he splashed the
water on his face
slurping and lapping it up
then the guard
materialized swagging swaggering over
like a goose as abraham put it
he shouted something in japanese and the
american coming to his senses pulled
away from the stream
abraham watched in dull disbelief as the
guard unsheathed his sword
with a quick ugly swish he brought the
blade down and cleanly decapitated the
american
the head plunked into the spring and
sank in a thin royal of blood
the body lingered for a moment suspended
in an upright position and then it too
toppled over into the spring with the
arms dancing in the water current
abraham noticed that the man's hand
nervously opened and closed like the
pinsers of a crab
i i i felt that in order to tell that
story um
you know i had to spend a lot of time
with abraham i had to get to know him
well and trust him and trust his
recollections and to look at what he had
already written and what he had already
testified in uh war crimes documents and
to kind of piece all this stuff together
with what i knew about his personality
and his sort of storytelling technique
but i felt like it was a lot more
powerful than to sort of tell to just
say there were there were men out there
who were decapitated to see it from his
point of view i think was a lot more
powerful and that's what i was trying to
do there
um
like abraham i'm dying of thirst um
maybe i should get some hold on
another problem that i i was
working with with the book was
how to deal with um the three years of
captivity these men were in the prison
for three years and one day was very
much like the next was like the next was
like the next
and uh it it struck me that to write
about this experience in the prison camp
and give it the
uh
the number of chapters and the number of
pages that that would require to
actually
accurately reflect the experience it
would be a pretty boring book basically
it would be three years of dysentery
three years of malaria three years of
filth and uh brutality and demoralizing
circumstances and i i worried that it
would be pretty tough reading for the
average reader to get through that and i
i decided that what i really needed to
do in that portion of the book the
middle passages of the book was to
get a different tone and a different
style and sensibility all together from
what i did during the death march was
really trying to get these scenes that
were very very vivid that i needed to
kind of
hover above the experience and try to
compress the three years into just a few
pages and that's what i what i tried to
do with what ended up being chapter five
which is the main chapter that sort of
looks at life inside the camp of cabana
tawan
it
is really about the psychology of
boredom
it is about
getting through the weeks and months and
years uh in which every day seems very
much like the next and
it's um
i hope it works i mean it's really
trying to kind of gloss over this whole
experience in a way that kind of gives
you some sense of of how it looked from
from these men's point of point of view
the tedium was excruciating
the
monotony the starchy sameness the long
spool of undifferentiated days
rice brains they called their
dull-witted condition
three years dragged on without plot the
primes of their lives floated away
unaccounted for
there was day and night rainy season and
dry
the navy chimes went off
each evening the same strains of
kimigayo
the japanese national anthem blared
through the tinny loudspeaker
each day had its little notches and
markings the trick was filling the long
gaps in between
while at their work they j they
daydreamed through the flats of the
mid-morning through the doldrums of the
four noon and on until lunch
the prisoners played games in their own
heads they pursued insipid discussions
based upon the flimsiest of facts one
prisoner recalled a long and heated
conversation he once had with a fellow
on the question of whether opossum's
penis has two
heads tommy thomas became an imaginary
construction worker back in michigan
where he was from
having been virtually homeless as a kid
growing up there he decided in the
prison camp that it was time to build
himself a house the exact house he
wanted to build in grand rapids one day
to live in nothing fancy a bedroom a
stoop a couple of dormers in the attic
brick by brick he built it up from its
cement foundation sometimes he couldn't
quite remember where he'd knocked off
during the last session
he never cheated though that was part of
the hard sad fun of it he had to get it
right down to the last brick no no
corner cutting no skipping ahead
there were rules to the exercise methods
in the madness of boredom
sometimes if he didn't have work duty
thomas liked to go over to section 8 the
medical ward for the mentally disturbed
and crouched beneath the window
there was a guy in there who would
broadcast
baseball games from time to time
the cubs would be playing the giants and
this poor baseball obsessed lunatic made
the play-by-play sound so realistic it
was astonishing
there might as well have been a radio
blaring people would get so caught up in
it that they forget it wasn't real the
announcer would go on relaying the game
oblivious to the wrapped audience
growing beneath his window
late arrivals would whisper
what inning is it
most of the time they dreamt about
food
they never tired of the subject next to
food
women didn't stand a chance
sex was a distant memory a vaguely
amusing problem not germaine to the
subject
the subject
was ice cream
georgia peaches
strawberry rhubarb pie asparagus with
hollandaise
if they ever made it home
they would surround themselves with food
they would start restaurants they would
get a deep freeze and fill it to the top
they would pool their money and buy a
grocery store
and never come out
some people fixated on exceedingly
narrow bands in the culinary spectrum
and their cravings drove them nearly
insane
when i was in there all those years
mostly what i thought about was cheese
said one private from detroit with the
31st infantry
i never ate cheese in my goddamn life
but when i got in there that's all i
could think about
over time the prisoners perfected the
sport of gastro-sado masochism
at night the men would swap recipes for
dishes that were ludicrously
obscenely rich
chocolate syrup on mashed potatoes
molasses and whipped cream over a whole
stick of butter
they would torment each other with
elaborate recitations of the meals that
they were going to prepare once they got
home
they'd be lying on their bunks in the
dark and without preface or provocation
someone would say
in a tone of perverse glee
bacon lettuce and tomato sandwich
everyone would writhe and groan
a few minutes would pass and someone
else would break the silence
new england clam chowder
on and on it would go until finally they
became sated and drifted off to
miserable sleep
as i said
the big problem in writing this book for
me was
how to get through this long middle
passage the three years uh you know it
just was going to be a very tough road
to hoe and and i racked my brain trying
to figure out ways to break it up with
uh maybe a chapters that would be about
what was happening back home um with
with some of these prisoners like some
of their loved ones back in their
hometowns or maybe there would be an
escape attempt or maybe there would be
uh
you know you've learned a little bit
about what macarthur was doing in new
guinea um
cutting doing something to ventilate all
of this uh starvation and dysentery and
disease uh because i i just sensed that
it was gonna be a a real problem for for
readers to get through this
and um
the thing that i came up with is it kind
of it happened by accident i decided to
write the the last chapters first for
reasons which i'm not i'm not sure why i
did it this way but um i decided to
write about the rescue the ranger raid
um first i think i wanted to know where
where this was all headed and i figured
if i got those chapters out of the way
then i would have a real clear sense of
of what was left and
so
that's what i did i imagined that i
would just have
uh
in the end a chronological book about um
there's there's the battle of of bataan
there's the surrender there's the death
march there's the prison camps and then
finally on about page 300 there would be
this ranger ray the great finale of the
book
um
but as i started writing these ranger
chapters uh
one of the one of the really great
things about narrative writing when you
really slow down and you start to tell
what was going on
minute by minute and and hour by hour
as opposed to what i just read which was
year by year
you start to fill up a lot of pages very
quickly what were they
what were they thinking at that
particular moment uh what were they
eating what was the weather like what
did the mountains look like um these
rangers remembered so many details
because those three days were
the most exciting three days that they
ever spent in their whole life
there's they
were able to triangulate their
experiences in ways that the details
were really flowing from from those
interviews and as i started writing
these chapters about the raid uh that
what i imagined was going to be just two
chapters became three four five and then
finally six chapters on the raid on on
just them moving across the landscape
and planning this thing and and finally
uh going to the camp and and the uh the
gunfire commences
and so i realized i realized that's what
i could use to break up the story uh
that you know i could go back and forth
between the prison experience and the
and the raid and create this sort of
syncopated effect uh with the two
timelines inching closer to to each
other to the point where they finally
intersect
hopefully with some suspense and uh the
gunfire goes off so that's what i ended
up doing um and i wanted to read
finally just a brief passage about
about the rangers and and as they're
creeping up to the camp and they they
get their first glimpse of the camp this
target that they've been thinking about
and obsessing about for uh
for you know uh 24 or 48 hours they
finally get they finally get to the camp
and they lay eyes on it for the first
time
late afternoon was taking on the
complexion of dusk
the sun's rays slanted low through the
high grass and the temperature began to
drop from the infernal to the merely
intolerable
a gusty breeze made a constant play of
swirls and ripples in the cogan grass as
though a distracted artist were
beginning whimsical thoughts and ending
them abruptly
after a half mile the tall grass fields
turned into rice paddies a quilt of
blonde stalks and black mud stretching
to the highway
the men adjusted their gazes all
conversation all joking stopped they
squinted and shielded their eyes with
cupped hands to break the glare
there it stood a tattered city of thatch
and razor wire swimming in the heat
waves
the view was hazy but unobstructed a
straight shot south
the rangers were startled and at the
same time a little relieved to lay eyes
finally on the target after three days
of thinking about little else to affix
an image to the strange word they'd been
uttering since colonel musee first
announced the mission
cabana tuwan
prince gave the signal and the men
stepped forward crouching in silence
they fanned out over the rice quadrants
in broad waves of thirty men
their boots crumped over the hard
cracked floors of the paddies scattering
flocks of field birds and reedy insects
rice stalks rustled in the fickle breeze
the men were silent but for the random
clicks and rattles of their weapons the
low friction of canvas rubbing canvas
after traversing one more square of rice
captain prince concluded that the danger
of detection was growing unacceptable
they had drawn within less than a mile
of the camp with the guard towers not
only visible but beginning to take on
definition captain prince lowered his
hand in a sweeping gesture and then all
the rangers fell to the ground
for the remaining three quarters of a
mile they would have to chart a slow
steady advance on their bellies
an army of snakes
lying on the crusty floor of a paddy the
ranger strapped their rifles to their
backs or held them out in front loosely
cradled in their arms then they dug
their knees and elbows into the dirt and
began inching forward pulling themselves
through the long straight rows
of dried rice
the ground was strewn with old carabao
dung and the flat expanses were
occasionally interrupted by shallow
puddles faintly spluttering with
tadpoles and schools of tiny fish
at one point a group of rangers
disturbed an unseen nest
and armies of red ants skittered over
them by the score
darting under their clothes leaving
trails of welts on
their arms trembled from a hard hours
game of playing serpent
they were drawing tantalizingly close
close enough to see movement inside the
compound and even make out the shapes of
guards perched in the towers
the late afternoon winds
had gradually abated an aladdin silence
fell over the plane the sun grew fat and
luxuriant as it lowered itself beneath
uh beside mount a riot the vast dormant
volcano to the southwest
in the sanguinary light the jagged ridge
lines of the sierra madre to the east
broke through in sharper bluer richer
blues
and the haze of the fields seemed to
lift
prostrate before enemy sentinels
enveloped by open earth and open sky
strung out over nearly a hundred yards
the men felt utterly exposed as though
the shinto gods might be following their
progress and waiting for the right
moment to impale them
i don't know why they didn't see us
recalled ranger alvi robbins there was
plenty of light if they had been really
looking with their glasses they could
have seen that there was something going
on out there that was not right
i wanted to uh see if you had any
questions and open the floor up for just
a sort of question answered period
informal just to
encourage you to ask any questions about
you know how i came to write this book
or or why i structured it the way i did
and let this gentleman here have time to
reach you because he's going to uh we
need to we want to make sure it's mic'd
properly
yes
i'd be very interested in knowing how
you chose the good storytellers and the
ones who would uh really open up to you
i'm sure many many of the veterans that
you met that you encountered had great
stories but how did you know when you
had the the final group right
that was the hardest part of the whole
book and the most time consuming part of
the whole book because i was looking for
veterans first of all that had to meet a
certain set of physical criteria they
had to have been in all the places i
wanted to tell and to have been in that
camp all the way till the night it was
liberated and many of the prisoners had
been in that camp at one time or another
but it had been sent off to japan to
work in coal mines or
had different experiences and it was
kind of hard to get your arms around
this vast
pow experience in the philippines so the
first criteria was working with the 500
or so men who were liberated that very
night in that rescue and working
backwards i had a roster of men that uh
that it was taking that that very day
as they were liberated
and it had their home towns and so i
went with with that group and i went
back to hometowns and you know worked
with the phone directories and tried to
locate people in many cases surprisingly
um you'd catch someone not necessarily
the person but a relative so many of
these guys were
like so many people in in that era from
little towns tiny little places ranches
and farms and small towns that
uh where there was really a sense of
place and you could usually find a
relative um
there are also some baton and corrector
organizations that i that i relied on to
find find people who kind of met that
criteria but then once i started meeting
people or at least meeting them over the
telephone
there was kind of like a mutual audition
thing going on where i think they were
trying to figure out who i was and was i
trustworthy and what was i up to and
i was trying to figure out whether they
were
trustworthy whether their memories were
um
sharp and uh whether their stories were
were good and whether they were really
willing to talk i mean that was the
biggest single thing is you know you got
to have someone who's really willing to
sit down and put in the the hours and
days that i wanted to to to do this with
and um
i guess you know
another factor in in all of this is that
i really wanted to end up with a
cross-section i wanted
i didn't want to have like five enlisted
men or three doctors or you know i
wanted there to be a diversity that
reflected the army of that day so uh in
the end i think i came up with a pretty
good mixture of people who are from
different parts of the country from
different branches of the army or
different ranks and i kind of wanted
that cross section and i think i think i
got that or it came pretty close
unfortunately a number of the guys that
i decided upon um as being
likely candidates to be to me main
characters of the book uh passed away
while i was researching uh and in one
case i i spoke to a spouse who said you
know he just he just died yesterday and
uh in another another case a main
character um i got through the whole
book all the interviews um we were about
to come out and just one one month
before the book came out he he died and
he's the kind of guy that would have
really loved to have seen this book out
and uh i think he was vain enough to you
know enjoy the limelight a little bit
and uh it was a real disappointment uh
to me that that he wasn't able to see it
come out but anyway that's that was sort
of the the way i went about finding
these guys i mean unfortunately they
weren't all located you know in one
central place they were you know all
over the country and i think i was in 30
some some states
and
and again i was really trying not
necessarily to interview
scads and scads of people i wanted to
interview a few people a whole lot um so
that you know you're really seeing it
from from their point of view um i went
to the philippines with a group of uh
veterans from world war ii but actually
none of those guys ended up being main
characters of my book
for one reason or another but i did get
to see the philippines from
the point of view of veterans which was
good because um the jungles of bataan
have been cut down manila is a vastly
different place the philippines have
changed so dramatically since world war
ii that it would have been difficult for
me to visualize what the what they went
through um
so does that answer your question
yes sir
that was quite a project that you've got
there i'm interested to see how old
learn
with all your research and
interviews how long did it take you to
write the book
the book project took about three years
um and at first i was just playing
around with it trying to figure out is
there a book here um
so i was doing kind of fitful research
um i really i decided to do this book
when i found out about an event that's
held here in new mexico called the baton
memorial death march
thank god they don't actually you know
recreate the circumstances of the death
march it is a military marathon held in
the white sands missile range and they
invite the veterans to come back and and
to sort of wave the runners off into the
desert and they run 26 miles and it's a
very moving event held on the
anniversary of bataan but there was
there was a the year i was interested in
this book there was a guy who was a
veteran from world war ii from bataan
who wanted to walk the route
to commemorate his comrades who had
fallen during the original death march
and i i decided to follow him and um to
write a story for sports illustrated
magazine about
um
kind of what the theme i was playing
with was synthetic suffering this idea
that we seem to be drawn increasingly to
uh to these uh sorts of um extreme
exploits in the in the wilderness and uh
uh purely optional suffering uh
and you know like paddling across the
ocean in a bathtub or
climbing mount everest without oxygen on
a pogo stick backwards you know just so
you can be the first and uh some of this
material i had encountered as an editor
at outside magazine where we would take
somewhat jaundiced uh view of all this
stuff but nonetheless it's out there and
i was interested in like okay this guy
participated in the real death march um
and here he is
on this
race with uh all these
men in their full
marathon marathoner regalia you know
bright clothes and uh running running
clothes and i think governor johnson
runs this event every year and uh the
governor of new mexico is obviously in
great shape and then
uh so i did this story and by the end of
walking those 26 miles with this uh this
gentleman named winston chilotto who was
a veteran um i just thought i was gonna
do a book and uh from that point i think
it took about three years and most of
that was researched the writing only
took uh well actually a little less than
a year i wrote it very fast i i'm i'm a
magazine writer and i seem to respond
only to deadlines and my editor gave me
a
a huge deadline and uh wielded it uh
without any uh without any remorse so
three years total
yes
he's creeping up on
can you expand a little more um than you
already have about the form
and how you determine that other than
that
juxtaposition and the style of writing
and how you
i mean is this something you a style you
adopted just for this material
or is this your usual narrative style
well
you know
my background is magazines and
outside magazine is a place i've worked
for five years
and they publish some real some what i
think
are some of some of the great works of
non-fiction of popular um sort of
adventure narratives like john
krakauer's into thin air and into the
wild and uh i certainly was greatly
influenced by that experience um
i i think that
one of the things that's always been
kind of a hallmark of an outside
magazine piece is that
you don't uh structure your pieces
around ideas or abstract uh arguments or
polemical kinds of um
uh construction you you construct your
your uh narratives around people and
scenes set in for real time where
something happens and each thing kind of
builds hopefully if it works well on the
next and on the next and it's it's kind
of a cumulative cumulative effect of
scene painting um when whenever you have
the details at least uh and they're rich
enough to paint a scene that's that's
what we always tried to do um and that's
certainly a technique i brought to this
project um
i think one of my biggest influences uh
certainly a mentor of mine in college
was john hersey who wrote hiroshima and
who was a big uh practitioner of this
form this form of uh of journalism which
uh you know what you want to call it's
kind of a hybrid it's it's narrative
non-fiction it's it's sort of history
it's sort of a straight journalism
there's some news in it i guess some
reporting in a traditional sense but
primarily um based on people and their
experiences there's an aspect of oral
history to it you know and i think this
book really in a way really is oral
history it's it's uh
it's primarily the stories of men as
they remembered them and as
as i was able to kind of cross-reference
and cross-check their stories uh with
the with the known facts
um
so
uh those are some of the influences that
went in into you know the structure i i
also wanted to
um
i was really interested in how to begin
this book because um
uh i don't know i got i got in my head i
was really
taken with the book the hot zone by
richard preston
some of you may remember the book it was
about the ebola virus and the opening
chapter the prologue of that book i'll
never be able to forget it it just grabs
you by the lapels and you cannot put the
book down after that it's very
frightening and it's basically involved
a guy on an airplane who starts bleeding
out of every orifice and he has this
disease but he doesn't know that he has
it and uh no one's ever seen this
disease before and the people in the
airplane are completely
you know they're frightened and they're
they don't know what's happening and the
stewardesses don't know what's happening
and and he's literally sort of imploding
before before the eyes of of of the
readers and it's very very scary but
it's an important opening i think
because it really explains what the
stakes are
how high the stakes are that this is
a very dangerous disease that we know
that we know so little about and that's
what i did i i
the opening of my book actually is about
something totally different a different
camp all together in the philippines and
an incident that took place there
the camp is called palawan and it's a
incident that i kind of learned about
accidentally
but 151 american pows were incinerated
by the japanese army just when the
americans were about to return
and the
the rangers returning to luzon
about to liberate the big camp uh had
some of them had heard about this
incident on palawan and it was a
cautionary tale it was the it was the
thing that everyone feared was going to
happen that the japanese were going to
exterminate the last pows rather than
let them fall into the hands of the
americans so that you know i open with
this scene not only because it's very
vivid and and i think very frightening
uh but because it really explains what
the stakes were um
why the the rangers felt they had to
risk their lives to go in to save these
guys before it was too late
so follow
no you you want to follow us
are you going to be writing the film
script
the uh you know universal pictures uh
his is working on it but they've pretty
much given me the uh polite uh
you know heisman you know they kind of
want to keep me at bay uh at least while
they're writing because i think from
their experience a lot of writers uh
have
uh hovered and too many cooks in the
kitchen syndrome
i don't know anything about
screenwriting i've never studied it it's
not
an art form that i know anything about
so i'll leave that to them my only role
that i want to play in the film if if
and when it's made is that is i want to
i want to try to do what i can to ensure
that it's accurate uh you know i think
many of us saw or heard about what
happened with pearl harbor recently and
and i want to do everything i can to
avoid that type of scenario um you know
i think it's not necessarily any one
person's fault but scripts kind of get
written and then they get rewritten and
they get rewritten and
next thing you know uh history's out the
window so i kind of want to ride that a
little bit um in a constructive way and
uh just to make sure that they don't
take it in in dimension i mean the story
is as you've already sent is graphic
enough and and um vivid enough and
horrible enough and also uh in the end
spectacular enough that they don't need
to embellish uh this is one they do not
need to embellish in any way
uh yes
mr tillen
was it easy to get overwhelmed by the
facts was it easy to get overwhelmed by
the uh
the amount of research you did i know
you also went to japan to research and
you went back east to research
and um
i saw many books in your bookshelf uh
you know at what point do you just put
it all down and say
i i need to be a storyteller here i mean
did
you have that question and i think it
applies to all
you know all journalism i think there's
a saturation point that happens where
you finally go if i read another article
or another document or another book i'm
going to explode and that happened to me
at a certain point and it happened
probably earlier than it would have
because of that aforementioned evil
editor who was a you know wielding this
deadline
i had to
put this put this stuff aside i mean i
could have researched this for 20 years
and not be done with it um i felt on
solid ground though whenever i was
working off of my interviews with these
men and you know it's very simple in a
way you know you're dealing with their
interviews their memories
in some cases they're non-published
books um
you know there may be a hundred books
written about baton but um i'm gonna you
know at that point in my storytelling
i'm gonna focus on this one man and
filter out everything else uh you know
hopefully the other stuff is sunk in
through kind of through the back door
and it's going to influence the way i
write about it but uh primarily it's
that one just that one source that that
one like ab abraham the passage that i
read was in a way a very simple thing to
write because
i was just focusing on him and any
anything and everything that he
remembered from from that day
what i'd read about the baton death
march the oral histories
i mean i've got more documents than i
know what to do with and i actually have
to figure out what to do with them i
need to donate them to an archive
somewhere um
i hope that influenced my depiction of
that day but but uh the primary material
was was was by far the most interesting
and i think the most helpful and
it anchors you i think as a journalist
to keep coming back to you know your
your interviews your original stuff and
and to try to tune out all the other
material that may be out there
yes
did you have a contract to begin with
what was the process of financing and
how did you get the editor etc
um i wrote a book proposal and rewrote
it and rewrote it um i worked for the
better part of a year
uh while i was still an editor um
because at that point i decided i wanted
to
to start writing full time and had this
book idea and
that was in many ways the hardest part
of this project was uh you know
believing in the project enough to to to
take a take almost a year to learn what
i could to read what i could to
investigate the other literature
other books that that were out there
and to write this book proposal and
you know book proposals can range
anywhere from 20 to maybe 100 pages
excuse me
and um
i worked on it and i had a a very good
agent who helped me kind of shape it and
reshape it and
i was very lucky in the timing because
when we finally did submit it to book
publishers um it was the day
very day that saving private ryan was
was uh was released
and
the book proposal sold uh because in
here we have really the biggest rescue
you may be in american military history
much bigger than saving private ryan uh
although that was a fictional story um
it was books sold within hours uh there
was a little little bidding war and it
was you know it was all taken care of
and within with it by the end of uh
business day and that was largely
because the editor who ended up buying
it bill thomas at double day was um
he was just real clear on this book he
knew from the beginning what it was and
what he wanted to do with it and how to
promote it and that it was essentially
at the intersection of two genres that
were uh popular right now world war ii
narratives and uh and which you might
call endurance or survival narratives um
because the largest portion of this book
is in the middle is not a military story
it's it's about men and uh and in some
cases women uh characters who are thrown
into these extreme situations and
they have to call upon all their
reserves
of stamina and
their sense of humor and their
ingenuity to get through this experience
so
um
so i guess that more or less answers
your question i mean i i didn't uh write
this whole book from scratch i did have
a contract and because of the amount of
research that was required to do this
book
to go to the philippines to go to japan
uh to go all over the country to go to
the archives and so forth i felt like i
really had to have the support of a
publisher um otherwise i mean i have
three kids and i have a lot of overhead
at home and i just i couldn't risk doing
this all uh
um on spec uh so so so anyway luckily
the contract came through double day was
very generous and we were able to
to
do all the travel that was necessary to
do the book
yes
[Music]
i just wanted to say but you mentioned
uh your introduction
uh
and uh
how it uh
you'd read this book book about the
ebola vac of
disease
and
how the introduction was so important to
getting people's interest in in the book
i i think that uh
when i picked up your book oh two months
ago
and read the first few pages i could
hardly put the book down you succeeded
very well
in getting my attention
and uh
it hasn't
and the only other book that ever did
that to me i might say was gone with the
wind
you can't put it down if you started and
i didn't i read your book straight
through yeah it's a great book well
thank you and and it is important i mean
i think that a lot of writers
particularly writers of history
think that it's almost um
vulgar
to to try to hook readers or to do to
use any of those tricks um any of those
tricks that uh fiction writers use um
essentially to pull people in to set the
story up and magnetize it and hopefully
in some sort of way that will get you
through it i mean and you know and i i i
disagree with that i think it's
important i think you know as soon as
you lose your readers what's the point
of writing the book i mean
you gotta you gotta not only get them
but you gotta keep them uh reading
because there are some important stories
in this book that i do think
have to be told i want these men's
stories out there
this was
a popular i was in i was deliberately
trying to popularize these stories
and i think there are certainly passages
that are really difficult reading i mean
they are hard to read and i think that
uh the opening certainly helps i think
to kind of explain
why why this
why this mission happened why this raid
had to had to occur and and just what
the stakes would have been had they not
gone in there and uh
liberated these guys
you're right
yes
yes after this
will you stay in the same area with your
writing i mean it's probably hard or
maybe it's too it's tempting to
uh think of what you're doing next or
perhaps you're already doing it but will
you stay with um narrative non-fiction
or can you feel this i think i will um i
don't think i'm going to necessarily
stick with war stories um
i've been on the book tour a lot of
veterans from the korean war have come
forward and have
urged me to try to look at some
different different aspects of the
korean war and i'm considering that as
one possibility but
i don't want to be i you know i don't
want to be uh a war a war buff i don't
want to be considered a war writer i'm
not that i was never
one of those guys who stays up late
watching uh the discovery channel and
knows you know every rivet on every you
know war machine ever invented
i
i come at this more from a literary
interest than a military interest
i don't mean to uh you know alienate
those readers because they're an
important part of my readership um
there are very dedicated military
readers in the military book of the
month club and and those those are
important readers but i want to i want
to dabble around in in some other areas
um
probably something much more current
i i definitely think that my my strength
is interviewing people and
if i go back far too far in history i
will lose that um
um
ability to interview people i'll just be
sitting in archives and libraries uh
working with documents so
uh the trick is to find stories that are
kind of uh
that are big enough and important enough
uh
from the point of view of being
important to to you know social history
or um
stories of consequence
but that aren't overwritten aren't
overexposed and that are recent enough
that you can find living participants uh
to interview so that's that's kind of
the that's the trick for my next book
and i'm i've been you know i'm still
promoting the book and um traveling
around the country a little bit uh with
this book so i haven't really had time
to to sit down quiet down and and think
about what's next
how we doing on time couple more
questions
yes
i read in the um
brochure that you have written for
outside magazine
so i'm
going to assume or i guess my question
is
what types of
uh
environmental things have you written
since i haven't
seen any of your articles in that
magazine
for the last three years or so i've been
working full-time on the book so i
haven't written anything uh in outside
but um
i i wrote a story for example um this is
the kind of stuff i think outside
when it's really hitting its stride is
is best at is um
there was a there was a flood a man-made
flood at the grand canyon a number of
years ago where they were trying to blow
out the silt uh and they uh
it was a very expensive experiment
basically and i got a call um just
before they were about to release all
this water from the glen canyon dam
and uh some friends of mine were had had
gotten somehow miraculously a rafting
permit to to to go raft the colorado
river during this man-made flood and uh
so um i said well you know i'm i'm there
i'm gonna you know i don't need to find
a writer i'll just be the writer um so i
um i got down there and we we rafted the
grand canyon and it was what was
wonderful about it is that
there was so much science going on there
was so much um
politics going on uh essentially the
bureau of land management and the army
corps of engineer and all all these
organizations were involved in kind of
trying to
right the wrongs of of
you know building the dam in the first
place and and to try to recreate the old
floods the primeval floods that used to
come every spring with the snow melt and
uh and yet it was also a rafting trip
and it was a it was a it was a fun
experience i was with
16 or 17
guides river guides from the colorado
river who who this was their basically
their vacation they weren't doing this
for hire they were doing this for fun
and i got to see all this from their
point of view the river guides are
really kind of a
subculture unto themselves the ones who
really have
you know worked on that river for for
years and years
and uh so it was a story that had sort
of science it had politics it had
um
you know spills um and uh you know lots
of passages describing the rafting uh
and it kind of was all intertwined and
that was that's an example of a story
that i was able to do that that i'm
proud of the that's very much kind of in
in the uh the purview of outside
magazines uh interest because ultimately
it was an environmental story
i don't know how successful that attempt
was in the end i think there's a lot of
debate about whether it really did
anything
but we learned a lot from it and there
have been some controlled floods since
and it did different dams all across the
country it's a very influential event
actually in water management
so um i don't know other stories i've
done stories about like
i did a profile of the uh of the skier
hermann meyer that was one of the
greatest skiers alive he recently was in
a
motorcycle crash
who it was the most difficult story i
ever had to write because i went to
austria
to interview him to spend a week with
him
and he wouldn't talk to me i mean he had
nothing to say and he had handlers and
he was a national asset in in austria um
skiers are are gods
and uh
the ski team is the best ski team in the
world and um so i had to figure out some
way to
get him to talk to me or learn something
about him and i ended up hanging out a
lot with his his uh his girlfriend and
um
and everyone in town thought we were
going out with each other and and uh she
wasn't too happy with him because he's
training all the time anyway so she was
very lonely and had a lot of time to
talk and that was that was that ended up
being the way into the story is is uh
herman meyer's very lonely girlfriend um
but anyway
i don't know if that answers your
question but uh i'm gonna go back to
writing for outside a good bit more now
that i'm uh
now i'm free from from this from this
project
we have time for one more
yes
ask you two questions
one was what have you learned the most
as a writer by making this i don't know
if this is your first book
and the difference between writing a
certain number of words
versus did you have a limit on words for
that book
um no there's no limit per se i mean i
think we all understood that this was a
big book it was an important book and it
needed to we need to give it some space
but at the same time we didn't want it
to be
600 700 800 page tome i mean i think
that would defeat the purpose of trying
to popularize this
event in history if uh if if the book
grew to such links that it would it
would be off-putting or intimidating to
certain readers um
i think the book is 340 pages or 350
something like that and that seemed
about right
um
i
um i forgot the first part of your
question was was
an article
oh i see yeah versus a book well um
magazine writing um
you know you are very conscious of the
word count and uh
you're paid by the word and your
story stories are always in the end cut
there's there's there's an art just to
cutting um
and
um
so it's very liberating to write a book
in that sense because you're not having
to worry so much about word count you're
not you know you're not worried about
how long it is but at the same time
the pacing of a magazine piece
certainly influenced the way i
structured the book if if i if you look
at the book it tends to
accumulate in increments of about a
thousand or two thousand words and then
there'll be a space break and there'll
be a shift in the scene or a shift in
the voice or or uh the momentum shifts
slightly and that's something that
there's no science to it uh well it's
seemingly about a thousand words
um no more than two thousand words is
you is usually
a concise
length it's but it's a link that works
uh at least for me
uh to kind of if you can't make your
point or advance the story however
you're trying to do it in those number
of words then you know maybe there's
something wrong with the singing and you
need to rethink it or something wrong
with the with the the passage that you
need to to regroup uh when they go on to
three thousand four thousand five
thousand words in a single stretch of
writing uh without interruption um it's
usually i think an indication that
you're not uh thinking very clearly you
don't know what you're trying to do with
that scene or or you know you just
you're kind of lost on the page and so i
think that very much influenced
the way i structured the book i mean
it's
it's a thousand words and then space
break and a thousand words in space
break uh
a chapter might have as many as uh 10 12
of those
uh sequences or passages and i think
that's um
pretty typical of of most writers who
come out of magazine tradition that um
you know there's a million ways to do
this and i don't you know i hate to sort
of say you have you've got to
you think about structuring a book in
thousand word increments that's silly
but but it works for me and it's sort of
a standard uh attention span i think for
for a reader to kind of think about a
certain wavelength or a certain vein
that they might be in and then move on
to the next one
i think we actually we have time for one
more
there's got to be one more question
i wanted to say one other thing uh
before we break this up um
in light of everything that's been
happening um around the world and
yeah i guess we all know by now that
that mr brokaw has uh has dubbed the men
and women of that era of world war ii
era the greatest generation
and to a certain extent i i believe that
the expression is accurate and justified
no american generation has had to endure
such large trials of history no
generation has been called upon to play
such a vital role in defending the world
from tyranny
but but now we find ourselves plunged in
a whole new crisis we're at war again
not with the germans and the japanese
but with a largely unseen and unknown
enemy
unlike in the philippines we don't have
the satisfaction of knowing
exactly
who we are fighting or even where the
battlefield is
because it seems to be everywhere abroad
and at home in our buildings in our
airplanes in our safest places of refuge
even in our mail
once again our troops will be called
upon to fight in hostile terrain against
a fanatically dedicated and elusive
enemy
the desert mountains of afghanistan look
every bit as forbidding as the jungled
mountains of luzon
and the troops who will in all
likelihood lead the way will be special
operations forces much like the rangers
described in my book elite infantry
pushing behind enemy lines into the
unknown making split second decisions on
the ground negotiating alien topography
to carry out risky missions in secrecy
as for us here at home which is also
perversely
a warfront
we must believe that the newer
generations men and women my age and
younger will face this trial with the
grace and courage and common sense that
characterized the efforts made by the
men and women of world war ii
we have much to learn from their example
we're having to pull together
to sacrifice in a way that was second
nature to them but is still very new to
us in the end i believe we'll discover
that mr brokaw's designation only tells
part of the story
that greatness is embedded not in any
one generation
nor in any one country
but rather in the human character itself
a greatness that reemerges whenever vast
challenges loom
thanks very much for coming to listen
today it's been an honor being here i
appreciate it and god bless america
[Applause]
generations of depression
is a contributing editor for outside
magazine and author of ghost soldiers
it's published by doubleday
for more information visit them on the
web at doubleday.com
you